michel fize est avec nous ce logo auteur
du livre une insurrection populaire au
destin encore incertain bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
les gilet jaune aujourd'hui certains
gilet jaune protestent notamment contre
ces interdictions de manifester dans la
capitale est ce que vous avez le
sentiment jury qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures concernant à ces interdictions
émise par la préfecture de police de
paris
je pense que bon le jeu d interdiction
est un jeu un peu un peu subtile
autorisée dans certains endroits non
autorisés en d'autres temps on voit bien
quand même qui a une stratégie de la
part des gilet jaune de se rapprocher
des lieux de pouvoir nous non pas pour
les saborder mais peut-être tout
simplement pour pour engager un dialogue
j'ai envie de dire qu'on assiste
peut-être de lapin d'aidé gilet jaune
une sorte de de harcèlement positif
c'est-à-dire d'un harcèlement qui est
conduit pour une juste cause ou
considérés comme tels
donc toujours les mêmes revendications
un sous jacent parce qu'il faudrait pas
oublier le fond donc une amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat une meilleure justice
fiscale une autre façon de faire de la
politique bon tous et tous ces objectifs
sont toujours en arrière en arrière
pensée mais ce que ces revendications de
deux départs ne sont pas dépassés par
celles beaucoup plus actuelle et là en
l'occurrence à des interdictions de
manifester on les entend moins les
revendications mais surtout le sentiment
d'être davantage concentré sur le fait
pour le valais qu'ils sont empêchées par
jean bie dire que la conjoncture prend
le pas évidemment sur les objectifs qui
sont en quelque sorte la structure de ce
mouvement
bon il est vrai que on peut s'étonner
qu'en démocratie outre les violences
policières auquel on assiste depuis
maintenant plus de 14 mois y ait ce
système de verbalisation à outrance
parce que il ya quand même un certain
nombre de gens qui sont empêchés à 135
euros évidemment c'est une somme par
rapport à des conditions de vie qui sont
souvent très très très compliqué un bon
et on voit bien du côté du soulèvement
parallèle le soulèvement que
j'appellerais multiprofessionnelle celui
des cheminots et autres catégories bon
évidemment avoir des bulletins de
salaire à zéro euro c'est quand même
pour le moins problématique est
injustement puisque vous en parlez le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune a été un
temps approché en par les syndicats au
début de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites lorsque les gilet
jaune mobiliser davantage est ce que les
organisations syndicales ont aujourd'hui
repris la main de la contestation
populaire
on le voit il ya quand même beaucoup
plus de monde aujourd'hui dans les
cortèges lorsqu'il s'agit de se
mobiliser contre la réforme des
retraites il y avait un moment ce lien
ce parallèle qu'on faisait entre les
jeunes d'un côté les syndicats de
l'autre quelle est votre bain je pense
qu'il faut surtout sortir du schéma
binaire on aurait tendance peut-être à
penser bon si c'est pas les gilet jaune
celle et gilet rouge cégétistes et
autres si c'est pas les syndicats c'est
les militants je crois qu'on est face à
une grande complexité et notamment dans
les modalités d'action donc à des
syndicats qui pousse les pions sur un
certain nombre de points
la base qui rattrape les syndicats pour
pousser dans d'autres directions
les gilets jaunes qui font honte
entendre d'autres catégories
je pense que la france est transformée
en une immense toile de révolte c'est la
raison pour laquelle de toute manière
même si ces soulèvements populaires et
multi professionnels venaient à
s'effacer progressivement il resterait à
mon avis quelque chose
qui est important nous sommes dans un
climat de révolte aujourd'hui permanent
on a beaucoup parlé entendent de la
convergence des luttes
la fameuse elle a eu lieu elle a lieu
alors de fait elle n'a pas lieu
mais il faut bien avoir conscience qu'on
a des juxtapositions intéressante bons
d'un côté le soulèvement populaire
incarnée par les gilets jaunes qui est
un soulèvement d'individus appartenant
dont catégories les plus les plus
modestes et de l'autre côté ce que
j'appelle un soulèvement
multiprofessionnelle la piloter jusqu'à
un certain point par par les syndicats
mais la convergence
elle est dans les objectifs 1 voir dans
les modalités d'action comme on le voit
jour jour après jour
donc je crois que on n'a pas besoin pour
le moment d'une convergence des luttes
pour évidemment perpétuer ce genre de
manifestations alors maintenant il est
évident que si on veut peser davantage
sur le rapport de force et le mettre
davantage à son profit il faudrait
évidemment envie envisagée alors je ne
sais pas peut-être une grande
coordination de de protestation qui
engloberait les professions les
catégories d'individus les villes les
campagnes
ça reste à faire alors vous êtes penché
de très près notamment dans votre livre
une insurrection populaire sur ce
mouvement des gels et jaune plus d'un an
après le début
de ce mouvement qu'elle comment est ce
que vous voyez comment est ce que vous
avez vécu l'évolution des jeunes
jusqu'ici je pense que bon les problèmes
demeurent
ce qui avait conduit au soulèvement est
toujours là donc il y à des personnes
qui vivent toujours dans des conditions
extrêmement extrêmement précaire pour ne
pas dire pour ne pas dire davantage
alors il peut y avoir évidemment une
certaine lassitude un resté quatorze
mois c'est compliqué allez sur les
ronds-points au risque d'être verbalisé
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui
devient un petit peu un petit peu
décourageant mais je pense qu'il ya une
grande ténacité je crois qu'on est face
à une société qui ne demande qu'à
changer qui a besoin d'être changé il
faut inventer absolument la société du
xxième siècle donc selon vous le
mouvement des gilet jaune va se
poursuivre en bas je pense que nous vous
ferons probablement le centième actes
dans quelques dans quelques semaines
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions michel fize sociologue
auteur dont deux se livrent une
insurrection populaire au destin encore
incertain